[موسيقى]
لقد قررت القيام
عملية عسكرية خاصة
[موسيقى]
سنكون معسكرًا عسكريًا طوال الوقت
بلادنا
لبعض
[موسيقى]
مفهوم
كلنا هنا ، معابدنا هنا هياكل
مشكوك فيه هنا نحن جميعًا نمنع
مرهونة دولتنا حتى تعطى
المجد لمسيحيينا المجد لنا
ورشة المجد لأوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
كل شيء على ما يرام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نحمله في السيارة
50 سنة
يرشون الكراهية
لقد شهدت مرات عديدة كيف
قتل الناس فقط كانوا يسيرون في الشارع أنا
شاهدت فتيات تعرضن للاغتصاب
واحد منهم قصة مخيفة جدا
قصة لن أنساها أبدًا
عمرها 15 سنة لها فتاة
أبقى في القبو
[موسيقى]
أولاً
لقد نجت من تدمير مستشفى الولادة
القصف الثالث أحضروا إلينا
خبرة كبيرة مع الأمهات كل من هو هنا
[موسيقى]
أنا قائد فوج آزوف المقدم DNS
بروكوبينكو
القادة متضخمون مباشرة في مصنع آزوفستال
هناك المئات من المدنيين مع
أطفال أثرياء أصليين من نوفيك
ذرب صغير من الناس في ماريوبول
[موسيقى]
واكتملت العملية
تحرير المعمل والمدينة
ماريوبول وزير المتشددين الأوكرانيين
الدفاع عن الاتحاد الروسي سيرجي
أبلغ شويغو رئيس روسيا
فلاديميروفيتش بوتين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
روسيا
إطلاق مواد كيميائية خاصة
لا سمح الله لا لب
[موسيقى]
إنها تتطور وجميلة
مرحبا سوف تتعلم
[موسيقى]
آلة الحرث ثم أنا أمثل أنا
سوف يمر الشلل ببساطة مع
بالحافلة فقط مع الحافلة وداخلها
محاطًا بالملح وكل ما أخرجه الرجل
أتحدث بشكل أفضل في مارس من أجل بلدي
من أن تتنفس هناك
القفز وبوتين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
خيار
جاء الناس للاستفتاء وقاموا بذلك
أن يكونوا مع وطنهم التاريخي
من روسيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ماذا حدث
[موسيقى]
كان هناك الكثير من الجنود الروس في كل مكان
اختفى الكثير من الناس من الشوارع
سرق الناس
[موسيقى]
حقيقة
حالة واحدة
نقوم بتنظيفها ليزا لديك تارجان
نقوم بتنظيف الإنفاق للحصول عليه مرة أخرى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]